welcome back to another video on code
Tecna toriel's we're continuing the lab
assignments last episode we finished up
set one of this first thing so basically
what I'm doing here is I'm just going
through these labs completing them all
and kind of over explaining them and
we're onto set - so if you want to see
some of the previous ones from set one
go check out the previous videos and
otherwise we're gonna move on we're
using cygwin on Windows and we're using
I guess what are we using Visual Studio
code or editor all right let's see what
this does write a program that swaps the
value of two variables without using a
third variable solution okay here's the
thing about this I know what it says
without using a third variable there's
always a third variable so if you hit
like if you call the swap function that
comes with C++ it has its own third
variable in that swap function yeah you
don't see it it looks like you're not
using a third but you are you just don't
know it because it's hidden behind the
library so can you even swap it without
using a third variable let's see what
their solution is cuz I don't know what
they honestly want here oh I see yeah I
guess you could do this huh there are
two numbers you know the two numbers and
then what does it want once a is now a
plus B and then B is a minus B a is a
minus B that's that's a really
roundabout way of doing swap I've never
done that before but all right let's
stop looking at the solution and just
write it ourselves let me just go into
our labs folder and I think we need to
make a new set yeah we do so make der
VARs set two and we'll just make a main
PP will also make a makefile this time
and let's just go ahead and open up
these files and visual studio code there
we go oh so I gotta put these in the bar
set to move move
okay there we go sooner make file we're
just gonna have a default and it's just
going to run everything compile and run
Hey there we go kind of like what we've
been doing now we're just gonna type
make and it'll do that command so let's
go back to our main we're gonna need
Iowa stream of course for our console
input/output and we have a way to get
info and show info to the user and let's
do this so swapping two numbers enter
two numbers and yeah we'll just do CN
twice we need some variables for first I
guess we'll do integers it doesn't
that's another thing about this lab it
doesn't specify it just has two
variables the value of two variables so
they could literally be anything any
sort of variable ever
I don't know this that's one thing
that's this misses so apparently they
mean integers which is specifically an
integer you know it's not like just a
variable it's a specific type of
variable but whatever so yeah that's
just something that annoys me like we
could literally make a really
complicated class and instantiate that
and swap it and be like there's our
solution and still be correct because
it's a variable and it's yeah whatever
we these integers then fine we'll use a
and B and we'll see in these a and B a
and then take B
so a and then B this is a little
different than what we're doing
previously and then okay so you take an
A and B and a and B have a value this
swap thing with the minus the way they
did it is not something they've done
before but let's think about this and
let's completing what no I'm not my
head's not easily wrapped around this so
if a equals a plus B now B is well-aged
just both of them combined right now
then we can say B is now okay's a - hold
a wait what
I got a look at the solution again I
don't know I didn't tend to do that but
we're just trying to wrap my head around
what they're doing here B is a minus B
is that right let's think about this
okay so we'll give it we give them some
values and we'll just see out right here
actual values a a B I'll just do it
we'll just do it like this it's kind of
like an XY type set up and it'll just
spit them out here a B and then a new
line character well I guess I could
surround them with parenthesis like so
that's means these have to be normal
quotes now because this is now a string
apparently gave me too many quotes
thank you for over helping me editor
okay so okay so a becomes a plus B and
then B becomes a minus B all right yeah
that's
yeah yeah that's right because basically
B would become the old a here because
whatever this is
now we're now subtracting off the the B
there's a really weird way of doing swap
and then now a is going to become B -
hey right
no a minus B because b is the new number
now okay I want to walk through this
just so it makes sense to everyone
including me okay so a becomes so to do
the swap without a third very well first
of all a becomes whatever a and B is so
a is now whatever B is at this
particular our way I'm saying that wrong
okay a equals a plus B and now B equals
whatever a became an - the B off of it
so now it's just a basically the old
original a and then we update the a it's
all about the order they update in now a
is still this original way but now - the
value of B let's see if this works
swaps your values and we basically want
this okay so let's see if that works
don't just make we got a change
directory into bars set to a now make
there we go swapping two numbers I don't
know let's put an 800 and space and a
500 and it seemed to work initial values
eight hundred five hundred watt values
500 800 excuse me okay so that
that does swap so that's a way of doing
it that's interesting I I've never seen
this yeah so I guess just note that down
if you want to use that method this will
only work for stuff that can be added
and subtracted together if it's there's
another thing here that's kind of hidden
between the lines you could say where if
you have a variable that you can't just
add and subtract together you pretty
much have to have a third variable or a
least a third place to put some
temporary memory and this probably does
that behind the scenes probably so just
FYI all right well this was question and
this was one let's go on to two and yeah
I don't want to spend any more time on
that but that's interesting
so I guess one of the reasons to do
these is I probably have stuff to learn
too that I didn't expect all right let's
go on to the second one write a program
which no they got some bad English here
I'll read it verbatim write a program
which input three numbers and display
the largest number using a ternary
operator solution okay so this is going
to be interesting because we have three
numbers of ternary operators pretty easy
to do with a single condition branching
in two different directions but this has
three different numbers now so the
ternary operator is going to be a little
crazy looking alright so basically we'll
take in three numbers so let's do this
real quick
enter three numbers and we'll go ahead
and I guess we'll scope this that way we
can reuse ABC okay so these will all go
out of scope after this is done and we
can we can do our own thing here and
I'll put this in its own scope to
something I talked about one of the
other episodes the whole scope and in
case you'll know if it is
but we want ABC we could also use XYZ we
could name them custom things whatever
it's fine
and we'll just enter three numbers enter
oh I've already said that oh my god
alright so we want a CN of a B then C I
keep typing the wrong thing alright
there we go so now we want to spit out
the largest of them so basically we're
going to do this largest is and then if
we need a ternary operator here so we
need a condition what it is if it's true
right here or it is if it's false right
here alright so ah it's gonna be a
little it's gonna be a little weird
looking and there's the end of it there
button we need parentheses surrounding
the entire thing so we felt this first
condition here let's say if a is greater
than B say okay so I a is greater than
or equal to B then we know a is the
biggest but how big is it so we go to
this cuz ace true it's bigger and we
would say well let's do another ternary
operator within the answer here so
that's gonna look a little weird some of
you and this autocorrect thing is
driving me nuts
I type parentheses and it gave me an
extra random one somewhere okay does a
autocomplete try if anyone else nuts
or is it just me I mean yeah sometimes
it's really helpful but other times it's
like oh I have an extra quote mark here
and when you delete it I'm going to
delete one way on the other side of your
line and just messes things up half the
time so I'm about to go to vim is what
this comes to alright the largest is
okay so if a is bigger than B then we
want to say we go to this true statement
which is going to check well is a bigger
than C so we do another ternary operator
within this true section here and let's
surround it very deep within print
sees itself so true and answer false and
answer I'm just using asdf as
placeholders
oddly enough so if now a is greater than
C then we can just output a because a is
the biggest one if it's not well then we
need to check let's see we already know
a is bigger than B so it's either a or C
and if if a is bigger than C then it's a
if c ends up being bigger than a then
it's C and the other third condition
what would be well B so if B ends up
being the big one or if let's see if a
is is it being less than B then B is
bigger but is it bigger than C we need
to check that so we do in this false
condition here on the original ternary
operator we do yet another ternary
operator with a true false and I'll put
some my asdf play soldiers here all
right so the new condition is now well
if it goes to this case then is B
greater than or equal to C because if so
the answer is B and if not the answer C
and there's the answer
let's put a new line at the end of this
so this whole giant ternary operator
will tell you which is the largest and
on the the equal cases I'm just you know
I'm just gonna give you the first one
basically it's with this do it so if a
and B equal are equal it's gonna say a
because that's just the way it's written
it's there's nothing in the question
about handling equal numbers so I'm just
kind of making an executive decision
here of if it's equal then whatever we
picked the earliest one that's equal
alright so let's go ahead and run this I
am going to skip this here and the one
way we can skip this
if we put a continue here right no it
has to be some sort of loop there right
it'll just work for plain old scoping
all right so let's just comment out this
for a second and we'll run the largest
is so we'll do a new make here let it
run enter three numbers I'll do a five a
six and an eight I'm just putting a
space in between those because if you
have them lined up like that they need
to be separated by a space or a new line
new line works too so it says the
largest is eight very good seem to work
as intended press it again and there
three numbers as time will do 8500 M -
and it says largest is 500 so it appears
and our initial two tests that the
ternary operator is working correctly
built away it is there so let's move on
to the next one three okay here we go
write a program that accepts amount as
integer and displays total number of
notes of Rs 500 150 twenty ten five and
one what except num wait write a program
which accepts amount as integer okay and
display total number of RS what on earth
is RS I've never I've never heard it
called this it looks like
understand I don't to be perfectly
honest I don't know what this means
I see the example and what he's doing
total number of our s what what are you
even talking about for example when a
user enters the number 575 those all
would be like this 501 a hundred to zero
50 to 120 ours and no number of notes of
ours I really just have to take a wild
guess here like could could they maybe
explain this in a way that is English
you know that would be nice or just
define whatever ours is ours I've never
heard whatever they're doing here called
ours so don't feel bad if you haven't
either or maybe you have and maybe I'm
the one being left in the dust here but
nope never heard of it so I have to look
at the solution cuz I don't know what
they're even talking about I just have
to guess okay so if someone entered 575
we would say okay well there's one 500
there's one 100 or there's no 100 I see
what they're doing they're just adding
it up it's like it's like how many
dollar bills would you need to make this
amount that's basically what they want
because there's one dollar bills there's
five dollar variables I guess they're
skipping the two dollar bill there's
tens there's 20s or 50s there's hundreds
there's five hundreds so they're
basically they're talking about as far
as I can tell they're talking about
money here and how many I think buy
notes they just mean dollars I guess
some countries they call notes and stuff
but I sort of used to that but this
whole ARS thing is throwing me off what
is it I don't know what that means I've
never heard of that still never heard
that even after this I guess I can say
I've heard of it but I will never I will
never curl correlate RS to dollar bills
because
doesn't work it's never been defined
like that for my entire life
it's like in solution I guess I already
know the solution is pretty easy
actually so we take the number and we
want to see just how many of each of
these it takes to build up to that
number and that's let's do that all
right
that's easy that's easy enough not even
understanding they're freaking in my
opinion wrong use of our language I can
still figure out this problem all right
so let's take in an integer see out
enter an integer that's some rhyming
words and we ate another whole dotty
thing there and a and C in a and then
we're going to so we're gonna have to
kind of design something to hold a
little bit more elaborate than usual
usual but we're both basically gonna
have to go through and subtract off
these and see how it goes so it's going
to be a bit of a flow of control sort of
looking thing in the end
but basically need to print each of
these and then print a number after it
showing how many it takes so I'm
actually gonna make another variable
here called
I'll just call it updated and that's odd
pated odd paid it updated and what we're
gonna do is first we're going to
standard c c out we're just gonna do all
these 500 i guess we'll do 500 here o
500 and i'll see you make sure we follow
it : and then we need to spit out how
many 500s it took right here so we need
basically a division type thing
first we'll say if a equals equals zero
I don't know is this exit negative one
or we'll say something
see how can't can't operate I don't know
we could just say all zeroes everything
is just going to be in all holes eros if
this is zero so if I guess it's not that
bad but basically what I'm getting to is
we don't want to divide by zero if we're
dividing by zero things are gonna get
all bad but well not we'll just skip
that possibility right now we're not
gonna worry about that but we could have
a little statement somewhere that says
if a is zero then you know don't do the
operation and just return
gtfo cuz it's not gonna work so right
here we need to output the number of
times 500 will go into this number that
we have so far entered and looks like
this episode's going a little over 20
minutes I'll just finish up this problem
and call it a day so all right let's do
this so how many five hundred let's just
think of some hypotheticals here what if
we enter in like fifteen hundred then
this should say three so what we're
gonna do is we'll just take a divided by
five hundred and that will give us an
integer and I think we want to floor
this as well so if we floor a divided by
five hundred
that'll round it down so if we have like
I don't know 19 if we have like 999 this
will just say 1 which is what we want
right okay so let's put a new line here
at the end and let's just test it with
our very first part I guess I could
write the rest it's not a big deal it's
actually pretty easy once we've gone
this far we just need to make sure we
update this variable so that's kind of
the tricky thing because we need to
subtract this 500 off of it as we go so
that the rest works
so the updated is going to be a - let's
see 500 times the floor of a divided by
500 so we're going to subtract out that
off that many 500 so whatever this ends
up being if it ends up being 1 we
subtract off one 500 ends up being 2 we
subtract off to 500 so that's that's the
point of this updated here that way we
can do our next process with the
hundreds and it'll look very much the
same you know we want to do very much
the same thing it's updated and let's
see should we should get a right answer
so it's just gonna look like a little
cascade of these numbers basically for a
while and 150 next 50 and I'm curious to
see if I nail this on the first try or
not maybe it will maybe I won't so this
is the 50 bill and then we got a $20
bill next 20 or grab this here and go
ahead and update so normally if you're
programming and doing something like
this you'd hide this all deep within a
function and just say give me the value
let the function handle it and if it
messes up the only thing you have to add
it is that one function that handles it
so you can kind of encapsulate it and
say hey I can't figure this out I want
to hire someone to work on this function
or whatever it may be and they can
isolate and work on just that function
and I'll mess up the rest your program
so a little rant they want to type type
in here but now we're doing the 10
dollar bill and we're gonna do this
updated once again except it's going to
be 10 and 10 and you might have noticed
I'm making a mistake here because I am
only updating this updated variable but
a is still the one being processed on so
what actually needs to be processed on
is a so
rather than using updated at all we're
just gonna update a and say hey now
equals a new value so this is something
you can do with C++ that's kind of kind
of cool is you can set a variable equal
to and then you can use it again on the
right side and it'll it'll calculate all
this first on the right side and then
update a afterwards
so these days over on the right side
will be the correct value until it's all
done so this should actually work we
don't need the second variable and there
we go
very good so if you caught that before I
said something kudos to you you are
ahead of the curve so this is the five
dollar bill now and the one dollar bill
last and we don't really need to do a
final update on a because we're done
processing and we should be good let's
see if we get the right answer here when
we compile this so when I clear this so
it goes up to the top and let's just do
a run we got an error floor it doesn't
like floor I think we need to include
see math or math dot H or maybe it's
just math apparently math doesn't exist
so see math okay enter an integer yeah
so see math is what has the floor and
absolute values and a lot of these
little additional helper commands of
course we could write our own but let's
just we don't want to deal with that
right now so let's enter an integer
let's do I don't know let's do nine nine
nine and see if we get the right answer
and so far it looks good because there's
one 500 and then four more 100 Springs
us up to 900 and then a 50 to bring us
up to 952 20s to bring us up to 990 no
tens needed a five rings of 95 and then
four ones brings us up to 999 so it
appears that that works very good all
right it's gonna do it for this episode
of completing C++ beginner labs starting
from the very beginning and we're gonna
go through every single one of these if
you want to see more of them as we
as we go go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you get some kind of
information or I guess the notification
button is more important if you want to
see when I post the next ones but if
you're a beginner and getting a C++ and
these are giving you a lot of
information highly recommended it's an
awesome language to learn it can really
do a lot for your future and yeah I
guess that'll do it also don't forget to
give this like if if you like it and
these out guys keep coding I'll see you
in the next episode